an average human lives for 72.6 years  but why don't we live for 200 years or  why don't we die within 10 years what  dictates our lifespan according to  ancient theories bigger than animal they  live longer for example a whale lives  for 200 years whereas a mayfly lives for  only one day but if we move around the  animal kingdom we see animals like clams  live for 500 years which are much  smaller than the whale  so what is the real basis scientists  found out that mutation rate might be  the key to answer this question a  recently published study in nature shows  that human accumulates somatic mutation  at fairly slow rate and that allows  human to live for longer whereas a  giraffe and a mole rat for comparison  have similar mutation rate and they have  similar lifespan note that their size is  quite different that means mutation rate  kind of dictates the lifespan  that's one minute see you next video